[Music]
you
hello friends welcome to this lecture on
perception which is making meaning out
of sensations one of the basic problems
with psychology is to take in the
physical environment to understand the
physical environment interpret it and
make meaningful observable
interpretations out of it so one of the
basic questions the psychology faces or
human beings face is to interact with
the human environment to interact with
the external environment
now psychology is the science which
makes us understand which makes us
observe or realize how physical inputs
are actually taken in are taken in by
our senses and interpreted into some
meaningful interpretations so we can
understand this by a simple diagram so
as I was saying the basic problem or the
basic idea about psychology is to
integrate hello friends this lecture is
focused on perception perception is
about making meaning out of sensations
what are sensations sensations are the
raw input which the brain receives from
various sensory organs sensations are
the stimulus which has been engaged on
different sensory organs and perception
is the process which makes
interpretations of these sensations in
this section we'll be looking at how do
humans interpret sensations which is the
basic information which is gathered by
different senses and how do we go about
making meaning from them it's a very
important part in cognition or in
cognitive psychology because this is the
first part which are the first step in
the cognitive process
think of this in terms of the computer
analog a perception is equivalent to
inputting something to the computer
system perception can be thought of as
the processes which take it input from
various attachments to the computer
various input device to the computer and
makes an interpretation sort of it
sensations are equivalent to things like
key presses on the keyboard push of the
mouse button or writing of the right pen
onto a computer screen which leads to an
electrical current and this electrical
current are then interpreted by the
computer system in terms of meaningful
stimuli perception is an important
process as it should be able to quickly
verify what is being inputted and also
should be able to distinguish between
different inputs for example if you
press the W key and the V key the
computer should be able to know when the
W key is will pressed and when the V key
is been pressed perception is a process
akin to similar to this but it takes
place in the human beings the perception
is actually a very complicated process
that's what most artificial intelligence
scientists would tell you for us it's
easy because it's a process which is
very natural to us now before
understanding require up the process of
perception let's understand a little bit
about what is sensation and even before
understanding sensation let's talk a
little bit about what psychology does
the basic aim or the primary aim of
psychology is to take in to understand
the physical environment and convert the
physical environment into a
psychological environment psychology is
the process through which
physical input is converted into
psychological input what do I mean by
that in the environment in the physical
environment around us we have physical
stimuli like light waves which are
packets of photons are sound waves which
are pressure differences created by
sound moving to the air not these
stimuli this physical stimuli is
converted into or is transferred into
the psychological realm and the process
which converts these physical stimulus
into psychological stimulus is
perception but even before perception
the fifth the physical stimulus
has to be read in the correct format and
inputted into the human system the human
computer and that is what sensation does
so sensation is basically a system which
takes in a physical stimulus like a
light wave or packets of photons which
are impinging into the eye and then
convert them into electrical signals
which are then passed on to certain
brain regions which pick up these
signals and depending on the strength of
the signal depending on the type of
signal it interprets what the signal
means now let's look at one basic sense
organ and try to understand how does
this really happen a basic sense organ
or a primary sensor again is the human
eye now if you look at the human eye
what really happens is there is a lens
with a lot of structures around it and
this is how the structure of the eye
looks like there is a physical stimulus
here and this physical stimulus reflects
light which is falling onto it onto the
lens the lens then redirects this light
into or onto the retina which has
photoreceptors onto it these
photoreceptors then look at or
understand the strength of the light and
pass these along through optical fiber
nerves onto the occipital lobe or the
occipital region of the brain the
occipital region of the brain then
parses the stimulus and tries to make
meaning of what the stimulus is the
process through which this light wave is
picked up by this retinal part of the
eye is sensation and
after that anything after that is
perception and so this is what
perception or difference between
perception and sensation is all about so
in this particular section we look at
object perception how does perception
take place so the basic theories are
what perception is about now since
you're not in this course we are not
focusing on to the brain too much or
looking at cognitive psychology from the
brain point of view we'll look at
cognitive processes from more of a mind
point of view so we'll focus more on to
those processes those systems are those
viewpoints which tell you about the
cognitive processes about the mental
processes which goes on in the mind when
some mental event takes place so what is
perception perception is a process
through which sensory inputs are
gathered and interpreted perceptions can
happen in several formats for example
perception could be visual perception
it could be auditory perception it could
be haptic possession construct early
perception so four or five different
senses and four or five different types
of perceptions perception which
basically require us to understand or to
localize where an object is what is the
object look like and what is the meaning
of our object now in this particular
section we'll focus more on to visual
perception since this is an area which
has been looked or which has been
diversity studied by most cognitive
psychologists so in terms of object
perception what does perception really
mean in terms of object perception
perception means understanding where an
object is in the environment what is the
shape of the object what is the color of
the object what is the texture of the
object what is the form of the object
and things like that
this is the first step of perception in
a later step these basic information
which was gathered by sensation or true
sensation are then mixed together and
interpreted into a meaningful whole into
a meaning and this meaning comes from
something called a process called
pattern recognition not an interesting
question
when a perception happens when we see
something does it imply that we also
know about it functions let's look at
perception from more basic view think of
any summer day you're sitting in the
classroom looking out through the window
of the classroom and what do you see you
see a green tree a bunch of bicycles
which are parked outside as it would
happen mostly in outside my classroom
some students talking a little bit of
grass a little bit of building and so on
and so forth the idea here is that when
you actually look out or when your eye
actually looks out of the window it is
not the tree that you see it is not the
cycles bicycles that you see the
vehicles that you see it is not the not
the building that you see or the shape
of the building that you see what you
actually see when you see when you look
outside the window is some kind of
information about various light waves
which are affected from these basic
objects into the environment so
perception is a step or is a process
through which these basic information
about the color about the texture about
the form of what you're looking outside
and making interpretation out of it
in terms of what is a building and how
is the building and what is a person and
how is it different from each other so
that's what perception will involve and
let's come back to the original question
which I just asked you is when we
perceive something when we look at
something and when we identify something
do we also go ahead and understand it
function now we'll leave this for a time
being and answer this a little bit later
this particular question has its answer
on something called the Gibbs Ronen
approach proposed by Jay Jacobson who
believes that as we see an object we
also see its function so the next time
when you see something new a new model
of a car do you also actually perceive
its function or something which you
which you have not seen before a new
model or a new type of object out there
in in the visual field in in the market
do you also perceive its function and
there's a lot of debate which is the
Newtonian view or Gibson believes that
most organisms when they look at
something they not only see the object
classify the object or understand the
object and make meaning out of it they
also have gathered some idea about the
function of this and that is this debate
between something called the classical
approach and the Gibson approach motapod
Gibson an approach a little bit later so
let's again start studying about the
classical approach to perception
classical approach to perception the
classical approach to perception starts
with identifying something called the
distal stimulus and something called the
proximal stimulus look at the figure
which we have here as you look at it
what we see there are two objects on the
field or on the environment these
objects have a particular shape a
particular texture a particular form and
light is reflected from these objects
onto the retina the retina looks at this
light and converts them into electrical
impulses even before that the light
which is reflected from these objects
fall on to the lens of the eye the image
of the object these objects into the
environment which forms on the retina is
inverted in shape so as you see these
objects an inverted image of this object
falls onto the retina this image which
is which is on to the lens is then
straightened up by through certain
processes and these processes
send this image back to the retina the
retinal cells are very specialized cells
they are not only able to tell you or
correct the orientation of this object
they can also at this very point at the
first step of perception look at or make
the the optical areas of the brain or
the optical centers of the brain provide
information about the various shadings
the various lights the various textures
the kind of intensity of light which
falls onto it the various edges and so
on and so forth about the object these
informations take it together when
passed on to the brain an interpretation
of it is made and this interpretation is
then compared with some kind of already
stored template and that is how
perception happens so basically the
objects in the environment as envisioned
by the classical approach is generally
called the distal stimulus and the one
the image the inverted image which falls
on to the retina is the distal stimulus
the interpretation of the distal
stimulus now understand the distal
stimulus is just packets of photon or
intensities of light which are actually
falling on
the lens and the layer later on to the
retina the interpretation of these
lights which are falling into a tree or
a box is what is called a percent so the
percept is basically the psychology
itself a psychological concept it's a
it's an interpretation which the brain
does of the proximal stimulus so
basically what I am trying to say here
is the distal stimulus is the object in
the environment the proximal stimulus is
the image of the object in the
environment or the inverted image or the
object in the environment but
recognizing an object or what an object
is
or the meaningful interpretation of our
object or distribution object as a tree
as an animal as a child as anything else
as humans as buildings is basically what
is the person now the percept actually
gets compared with fixed patterns which
are stored into the brain and this is
called pattern recognition
once the occipital areas gather
information from the eye the optical
nerves about basic informations about
the proximal stimulus such as the
shading of the stimulus the contours of
the stimulus the kind of intensity of
light which is falling on the stimulus
from there a meaning is interpreted and
this meaning is interpreted in terms of
comparing what the occipital lobe has as
an input from the eye and comparing them
to pre-stored concepts to pre-stored
input and representations which are
already in in the brain this process of
comparing the input from the eye to
priest or deeper representations in the
brain and making meaning out of it is
called pattern recognition which is the
rig
so pattern recognition is the
recognition of a particular object or
event as belonging to a particular class
or even
pattern recognition is the process which
makes you differentiate between two
kinds of trees or two kind of people in
computer science pattern recognition is
very important as pattern recognition
lets you identify clusters or visible
patterns in huge amounts of data what
are the most prominent problem in
computer science is having a lot of data
but not finding patterns in it not
finding clear identify patterns into a
lot of data and what are the solutions
of interpreting a chaotic data or huge
data is to find similarities finding
similarities between items is what is
called making classifications or making
patterns and then identifying these
patterns with restored pattern is what
is the process of pattern recognition so
a similar process happens here as you
can see in Figure B and C the actual
retinal image is always inverted but
what really happens is the eye
reinterprets this or we correct this
particular thing into the actual image
now one of the basic debates here is
whether distal stimulus
which is the image that is in the
environment and the proximal stimulus
which is what forms into the eye the
debate that most psychologists our
perception psychologists have is where
the distance simulus is equivalent to
what a percept is so whether the distal
stimulus the stimulus in the environment
in in our case if this is the eye and
this is the lens and this is an object
in the environment and this is the light
falling from the Sun which is being
reflected here this is called the distal
stimulus this is called the proximal
stimulus and this is the brain
interpreting this image as a percept now
the debate has been whether this percept
is equivalent to the distal stimulus
many a psychologists have debated this
and the idea is that they are not clear
do a small experiment to see what do I
mean by this the percept the meaning
that the brain does or the brain makes
of anything in the environment is
entirely different from what actually is
in the back and so brain recreates or
adds on to certain things adds on to
certain values - or certain elaborate
interpretations to what the proximal
stimulus is a small experiment to
basically tell you the difference
between what a percept and water distal
stimulus is extend your hand in front of
you and slowly bring the hand towards
you what do you think you see your hand
moving towards you but do you see or
when you see your hand moving towards
you actual physics says that as the hand
moves away from you it's size on the
retina is small and you should see a
smaller hand whereas when it moves
towards you the size of this
: hand increases as the distance between
your eye in the hands increases so you
should see a bigger image but is that
what you see is that what you feel no
when the hand is extended and when it is
near the high at both the times the hand
your hand has the same shape or the
percept of the hand has the same shape
which basically proves the fact that the
proximal stimulus the changes in
proximal stimulus do not make changes
into the percept and the percept is
entirely different from what the
proximal stimulus is this particular
feature is called size constancy a
feature of a perceptual system which
maintains sizes of things more about
size constancy in later units now one of
the basic things in perception is to
identify what is in the environment and
one of the basic approaches for that is
the gestalt approach let's start with
the gestalt approach look at the figure
displayed on your screen what do you see
there are two interpretations of this
figure it could be that white birds are
flying towards your right or it could be
the black birds are flying towards your
left these interpretations depend upon
which part of the figure which part of
the image you consider a figure and
which part of the image you consider as
the background and that is what Gestalt
is say the basic interpretation basic
idea of get guest artists in terms of
perception is what is figure and what is
background what part of an image is
figure and what part of an image is
background and this is the first
distinguishing that happens in terms of
making the person these kind of images
is called are called reversible images
look
this image what do you see most people
when they see this image they see an old
woman but if I tell you that this is a
reversible image and you also can see a
young woman not of it you'll be
surprised but then I can show you how to
change this figure or how to change this
picture into a young and old woman this
part over here that I'm highlighting is
what creates the difference the red
color part becomes the mouth of the old
woman whereas it becomes the necklace of
the young woman and as you see this part
over here becomes the nose of the the
young woman and the eyes of the old
woman so basically then forceps or
meaning that I made from physical
stimuluses depends a lot about subjects
motivation subjects expectations and a
basic process about understanding what
is the figure and what is the background
so let's look at jump into one of the
first approaches in understanding
perception there are several theories
which is out there which help you
understand perception one of the basic
theories that we are going to talk today
about is Gestalt approach to perception
now another first primary interpretation
of Gestalt approach is they start
approach it interprets visual perception
as how as interpretation of stimulus
arrays into objects and backgrounds
waters gets that approach start with
what is the starting point of a gestalt
approach the astark approach believes
that processing of a percept start
starts by
parsing or interpreting the visuals the
stimulus the visual stimulus or
electrical patterns which are
transferred from the eye into foreground
and background so interpretation of an
image interpretation of a visual field
we'll start by first distinguishing that
into foreground and background so the
first step into the understanding of
figure calling to Gestalt approach is
basically parsing or interpreting the
figure in the background as we saw in
these figures as you change the object
as you reclassified a figure as a
background and background as a figure
the meaning of the image changes
look at this figure this is again a
reversible figure now depending upon
what you're looking at or where you are
focusing your background and foreground
is that will define define what the
figure actually means if you consider
bad white as the background and black as
the foreground you actually tend to see
start seeing two people facing each
other
but reverse this if you make black as
the background and white as the
foreground you start seeing immediately
start seeing the image off of us this
particular feature of distinguishing an
object of perceiving an object as a
figure in background is called foreign
perception according to the guest artist
what does this help us with
understanding or breaking something into
figure in background breaking an image
into figure and background helps us with
several things first the figures tend to
have show better shapes and tend to be
remembered better than the backgrounds
as soon as you interpret a visual
environment two figures in backgrounds
what really happens is the contours of
the figure the idea about the figure or
the part of the back of of the image
which you consider as figure is
remembered much better with much better
perception then the background now from
perception happens when we actually are
able to classify part of it this image
into figure and into background now
distinguishing the figure enter back
into distinguishing a visual field into
figure and background requires us to
understand or markup subjective contours
now these contours will actually define
what a figure is and water background is
for example in this particular figure as
you can see these lines are the contours
which define what a figure or an
background is the gestalt psychologists
they believe that perceivers follow
certain laws or principles of
organization in interpreting any percept
or any kind of perception and one of the
first laws that the guest artists were
hooked up to or they proposed is
something called the law of whole and
part what is the law of Golden Path
guest artists believe that means when we
perceive something when we perceive an
image when a perception of an object or
event is done the perception is in terms
of the whole object or even it is not in
terms of parts of the event or object
and that is why the guest artists are in
j-just direct opposition to what the
structure is believe now the
structurally school of psychology
believe that any mental event any mental
process can be broken down into its part
and it could be studied that way for
example what guest artist would say if
you're looking at a cold lemonade the
cold lemonade can be broken down into
the idea of a cold lemonade the
perception of a cold lemonade can be
broken down into its physical form which
is in terms of its temperature sweetness
bitterness which are all physical
quantities and also in terms of the idea
of what this lemonade would taste like
in terms of sarna's in terms of
sweetness so the psychological part of a
lemonade or the psychological content of
a lemonade is the taste and the feeling
that you get after drinking it whereas
the physical part of a lemonade
we'll move its coldness its temperature
its sweetness its saltiness and so on
and so forth so a basic opposition to
this particular aspect to this
particular school was provided by the
guest artists who believe that it is not
possible or it is next to impossible to
interpret perceptions to interpret
meanings about objects in terms of holes
in holes and parts in terms of parts
what they believe that any perception
has to be in terms of holes and also
that holes the hole of an object is
always different from a part remember in
the first lecture on introduction we
looked at briefly on the gestalt
approach and there I said to you that
the holes are not different from its
part is one of the prepositions of the
gestalt approach there I brought for
what for a foreword an explanation and
I'll borrow that explanation again if
you are hearing a song the song has
lyrics has music and several other
things included into it so the feeling
that you get after hearing a song will
not be equivalent when you hear the song
in parts meaning which if I first make
you hear the lyrics later on I make you
hear the songs instrument playing and
several other things one by one for the
come the meaning of the song or the
feeling that you get after hearing the
song in parts will not be equivalent to
what it will be in terms of holes and
that is what guest art is safe guest
artists say that perception is generally
in terms of holes and these holes are
divided into figures and backgrounds
part perception is not possible and one
of the reason for dividing a perceptual
environment in the figures and
background is because when you divide a
particular environment into figure and
background the figure is the one which
is perceived and the back
the one which is not perceive is is the
one which is supporting you and as soon
as you change meaning changes a good
example to bring here is the image on to
my right bottom look at this image what
do you see it's a dot image which has
been created by psychologists to
understand how perception works and as
you will see that this image has several
dots into it it's this was created by a
fine art painter and if you look closer
if you go closer to the image all you
see are dots and patterns several dots
black dots and on on white backgrounds
but as you move yourself away from this
image and as you put start put putting
something called top-down processing
start thinking about it or start
deliberately making meaning out of it
sooner or later you will realize that
you see a dog a shape of a Dalmatian
here this Dalmatian the shape of this
Dalmatian here is what is the meaning
that we get from this particular visual
field and this happens only when we are
able to separate this shape which now
becomes a figure and everything else
which is the background now guest
artists they came up with or they
proposed several principles are several
organization principles which make
people help in making successful
perceptions we will discuss some of this
although there is a list of perceptions
of perceptual principles organization
principles the guest artist what we'll
discuss some of them here there are five
major perceptual organization principle
and guest artist the first is called
proximity or nearness principle it says
that when objects are close together
they are perceived as together
then when objects are far away from each
other look at the figure on the bottom
of your screen what do you see
you see and when I ask you to interpret
this what most people are going to
interpret is that there are dots blue
and red dots columns of blue and red
dots
although nowhere it is clear whether
these are called amps of blue and black
dots but people Club these blue and
black dots since they are close together
since they are proximal together into
one and now they say there are most
people try to explain this figure as
four columns and of repetative blue and
black dots and this is what the
perception of Prague the principle of
proximity really means principle of
proximity says that when two objects are
brought together or when multiple
objects brought together they are
combined into to get into togetherness
or they are interpreted as together and
this is one of the principles of
organization of perceptual organization
which helps us in making perception in
understanding or making interpretation
of the visual field a second principle
that the construct is proposed is the
principle of similarity what does this
principle say it says that in if in a
visual input or a visual field we have
objects which are similar together we
tend to Club those items which are
similar as grouped together and so when
I ask people to interpret what this is
and when I asked my students to
interpret what this is
most people come up with answer saying
that there are two rows alternating rows
of red and white dots now when they say
two alternating rows of red and white
dots they Club the red dots together and
white dots together
a third principle is a principle of good
continuation
this principle suggests that when we
group objects together whose contours
form a straight line or a curved angle
they are grouped together so when I
asked most people to look at this
particular image since these objects
share a curved contour it's most people
actually go ahead and say that this is a
wave pattern whereas most of us can
disagree today saying that it is not
wave pattern as this and this part this
in this part this and this part can be
separately different but most people see
these as wave pattern because the
contours of these lines are similar are
forming an arc a fourth principle is a
principle of closure looking at this
most people tend to interpret this as a
circle whereas this is not a circle now
the brain what it does is using a
principle of closure it tries to make or
close this figure to make it to make the
easiest interpretation out of it and the
easiest interpretation of this figure is
the circle the brain feels of the gap
which is there into the image the fifth
principle is a principle of common faith
this principle is difficult to explain
on 2d surface but then a basic idea is
that objects which move together in a
particular direction are grouped
together as you can see since these
objects tend to move on the upward
direction and these objects tend to move
on the downward direction they group
together as moving together and that's
why we say there are groups of balls
which are moving up and which are moving
down what is the need of the gestalt
principles one of the basic needs of the
gestalt principle is that it helps us
into organizing the but the perceptual
details the
details from the visual environment and
make meaning out of it the style
principles help us into organizing the
information which is coming on from the
senses together to make some meaningful
interpretation and Gestalt principles
the organization principles of Gestalt
also help us in a quick pattern
recognition
another important gestalt principle is
something called the law of branch
it's against general principle which all
other principle which holds all of the
principle and the interpretation of this
principle is that the simplest meaning
is always the most correct meaning what
this principle says that looking at
anything the most simplest explanation
that is available for a particular image
for a particular event or idea is the
most correct idea or most correct
interpretation of that event or or image
looking at this particular figure here
most people can define it in number of
ways but the most simplest explanation
of this is squares which form chain as
you can see these squares actually tend
to form a chain in the most simplest
interpretation of this is that squares
which are arranged in chain now the
gestalt approach is not without
limitations there are a number of
limitations to this particular approach
one of the most basic limitation to the
gestalt approach is that these are this
particular principle or gastral test
view cannot be translated into cognitive
or physiological process there is no one
to an agreement of how these principles
of organization of the gestalt gets
translated into cognitive processes or
what cognitive processes actually come
into plate what physiological processes
or brain processes come into play when
these principles are in operation
another interesting or I would say
another limitation of this approach is
the circularity of the
pranks if the simplest explanation of
this figure is the triangle this happens
because it is the simplest figure or the
most eligible stable figure that I can
see I can go circular about it saying
that since this is the most stable image
I can see about this the most actually
actually the effect that I see about
this is the triangle and so this the
simplest interpretation into it so it's
it's circular in nature the prangs law
is circular in nature and without
additional information the law of pranks
doesn't actually go ahead and interpret
anything or give any meaningful input
thank you
[Music]
you